[Música]
revista de prensa en directo América de
Francia 24 Marta Moya ya está con
nosotros en el estudio Marta bienvenida
buena mañana de viernes ya finalizando
una semana bien movida noticiosamente
vamos a empezar entonces en Italia Marta
Porque las puertas de los comicios
generales de este domingo están ya casi
que abiertas en los medios empiezan
también a hacer esta previa de la
contienda electoral donde la
ultraderechista Georgia melón y parece
según indican todas las encuestas que va
a ser la nueva primera ministra de
Italia Así es Raúl buenos días semana
como decías intensa en la prensa
internacional y abrimos con el corriere
de la cera que titula efecto Band Wagon
En referencia a este subirse al carro
ganador para meloni en las elecciones
pero si hubiera una sorpresa y el
corriere de la cera plantea dos
escenarios dice que fratelli de Italia
hermanos de Italia el partido de Georgia
meloni pues se ha mantenido estable como
primero en las encuestas y que bueno
pues durante estas últimas semanas
cuando se pueden publicar encuestas en
Italia hay otros métodos que también
bueno metros subversivos que también
implican y también dicen que Georgia
meloni será la nueva primera ministra en
el país alpino dice el correo de la cera
se pregunta habrá sorpresa y Bueno pues
sostiene que las últimas elecciones
italianas todos aquellos que se
planteaban como primera opción han
ganado y además han ganado con más
porcentaje Y esto es lo que se refería
al corriere con el efecto de Band Wagon
subirse al carro ganador puede George ya
melón y pues aumentar sus perspectivas
electorales o por el contrario Dice
puede desmovilizar a la gente Pues que
ya entiende que ya ha ganado Y no y que
no la voten vamos a ver entonces el
domingo sabremos si la señora melón y
será la nueva primera ministra italiana
vamos ahora que dice el medio político
sobre este tema también Marta pues
político le hace un perfil a esta
candidata ultraderechista y dice pues
que si gana las elecciones se convertirá
en la primera primera ministra mujer del
país alpino sostiene Pues bueno hace un
balance de toda esta carrera política de
la ultraderechista empezó bueno sus
inicios con 15 años en las juventudes
del movimiento social italiano que son
Los herederos del partido de Mussolini
ayer era la única mujer y poco a poco
pues fue ganando cuotas de poder y bueno
sus colegas dicen de ella que lo que le
hizo ascender fue su ferviente
Patriotismo y un impulso a la rebelión
en 2008 se convirtió en ministra de
juventud bajo el gobierno de berlusconi
Y bueno pues su ideología está basada en
los intereses nacionales las fronteras
nacionales es antidrogas anti abortista
y bueno Déjenme mucho la política de la
identidad fuera de la fronteras
italianas la prensa europea también
refleja hoy viernes en sus portadas este
ascenso de melón y un poco la
preocupación de la posible victoria de
meloni Así es empezamos con día
economics que le dedica portada este
viernes y titula debería preocuparse
Europa Georgia meloni y la amenaza de la
derecha italiana Y es que bueno pues a
raíz de esta Bueno más que posible
Victoria electoral también hay
preocupación en el seno de la Unión
Europea por su programa bueno
controvertido vamos ahora con liberación
de Francia Marta también hay como
unanimidad de las portadas europeas
alrededor de las elecciones italianas y
Liberación dice la extrema derecha A las
puertas del poder claro digamos que
atenta de alguna manera contra los
valores europeos y que dice el país de
España el país destaca una foto de los
tres líderes de la coalición de derecha
Silvio berlusconi por Forza Italia
Mateos albini por la lega Y pues la
candidata favorita George George meloni
por fratelli de Italia y destaca la
derecha italiana se entrega al liderazgo
de la Ultra meloni porque ayer en el
acto de cierre de campaña en Roma meloni
obtuvo todo el protagonismo y vamos a
seguir hablando de extrema derecha Marta
Pero esta vez en nuestro continente en
Estados Unidos porque la prensa recoge
estos últimos días los vínculos entre el
ex presidente Donald Trump y los grupos
de extrema derecha como elecciones sobre
todo a raíz de unos últimos actos o
públicos de Donald Trump donde son una
canción muy parecida al himno de este
grupo alrededor de toda esta polémica
causada por un mitin en Ohio donde
Donald Trump Bueno pues hizo sonar una
canción verdaderamente parecida al himno
de cubanon El Boston globe hace Bueno un
análisis operativo acerca de este tema Y
dice Bueno pues que el matrimonio entre
Donald Trump y q'anon se ha gestado en
el infierno sostiene Pues que en un
reciente mitin el ex presidente consumo
un largo coqueteo con el grupo
extremista destinado a terminar en un
abrazo mutuo sostiene además que Donald
Trump Bueno pues en los últimos años se
ha dejado llevar por este grupo de
extrema derecha que bueno considera y
crea teorías conspirativas alrededor de
los demócratas y alrededor de cosas
tremendamente bizarras y alrededor Bueno
pues de cuestiones Trump ha abrazado y
sostiene bueno que el presidente el ex
presidente podría estar abrazando a esta
teoría para lanzarse a las elecciones de
2024 que dice esto
destaca que en tiktok estos vídeos de
cubanon se han vuelto a hacer virales y
es que aunque la plataforma en 2020 vetó
Y puso bueno palos en las ruedas a los
contenidos de este grupo de extrema
derecha ahora pues han como
decirlo han
jugado alguna manera
Perdón han cambiado sus hashtags y Su
contenido ha vuelto a la plataforma y se
ha vuelto a hacer viral sostiene Pues
que este medio estadounidense ha hablado
con la plataforma y ha dicho que bueno
Están fiscalizando el contenido pero
parece ser que no no está siendo
efectivo Marta como siempre Gracias por
toda la información revista de prensa le
ponemos Punto Final Entonces por esta
semana el lunes por supuesto volvemos
con más gracias feliz